und jetzt der feine kill der vielfalt
und er ist nicht schlecht equipped ist
nicht schlecht aber wir haben mal
getroffen mit dem bogen und er ist
scheinbar als besonders beeindruckt
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren kick vorstellung ja es
macht einfach bock hier die kids
vorstellung heraus zu ballern in der
games und wir gehen davon mal direkt in
die runde rein ganz trocken
trockenreifen nach wie einfach einfach
mehr sagt ja nicht ewig hier wird
spielen würde den die ich wollte immer
zeigen was den dieb so alles kann der
dieb hat der folgenden text
er kann ender kisten mit einem kick
blick komplett lernen ist relativ kurzer
texte man sich mal die anderen so
anschaut was vor allem daran liegt dass
der dieb eben einfach nur diese eine
fähigkeit hat und ansonsten eben pvp
kein vorteil besitzt lediglich diese
fähigkeit hat diese kisten mit einem
klick zu lernen dies aber dafür dafür
dass man dann im laufenden spiel keinen
vorteil hat oder einen geringen vorteil
ich dafür ist die am anfang extrem
nützlich weil man einfach hier
zack zack zack zack zack alle kisten
anklicken kann und dann den inhalt von
von jeder kiste so zusammenkommt was
ziemlich cool ist ich werde es euch
einfach mal zeigen in fünf sekunden
geht's los und dann ihr könnt übrigens
aber in die kommentare schreiben
ob ihr diese kit vorstellung lieber
haben wollte wenn ich allein spiele oder
ob es bevorzugt wenn da jemand mit dabei
ist und mit spielt mit redet wie ihr das
wollt könnt ihr einfach in die
kommentare schreiben
weil ich mir jetzt echt gedacht habe so
kipp vorstellung sind eigentlich auch
mal alleine ganz lustig andererseits ist
aber auch ein relativ reguläres gameplay
deswegen kann da ich schon auf mein
partner vertragen wie ihr wollt in die
kommentare
wir machen es jetzt mal schön hier den
crafting table den obligatorischen immer
einfach in jeder runde neu macht es so
eine krasse routine
hier ist tritt und ihr seht ihr einfach
elf gold bekommen also echt extrem viel
weil wahrscheinlich so material aus drei
kisten oder so naja uns an den unter den
nagel reißen konnten
hast du nummer lederschuhe in leder
henry lange schon zack zack zack dann
kann uns jetzt eigentlich fast nichts
mehr passieren
die erfahrung sprechen dollar generieren
und dann schauen wir doch jetzt mal wie
gut sich so ein dieb im pvp beweisen
kann aber erst mal opfer und anklicken
das niedrige nehmen wir auch noch mit so
und die anderen spieler egal
auf jeden fall haben jetzt hier noch
noch einmal 44 eisen erhalten schnell so
ein paar schuhe machen und aus dem gold
erhalten noch mal acht gold eine leggins
also immer noch ein bisschen besser wird
und da kommt auch schon der erste gegner
er sollte eigentlich jetzt mal kein
problem sein weil ich mich aus dem
fenster lehnen und das warten nicht
allzu schwer das ging wie man diesen
block damit und der nächste gegner ist
31 prozent davon ist
sagt er es auch weg das auch relativ
unproblematisch also der dieb stellt
sich gar nicht so schlecht muss ich
sagen da für das er eigentlich ja
eigentlich nur klauen kann wird sein die
kisten cloud deswegen auch die auch von
vielen gehört dass die pc-version
passender name wäre für dieses kit was
jetzt nicht unbedingt findet okay er
kann jetzt die männer aus dem inventar
klar und das stimmt andererseits kann er
aber sagen eine kiste clown oder anderen
die wenn man wenn jetzt zwei drei leute
versuchen sich aus einer kiste was zu
schnappen
dann kann der dieb in der hinsicht clown
als er den anderen dann einfach die
items volle nase wegschnappt
du bist snacken unterwegs vorher
aufkommen gesorgt
78 glocke bekommen näher kommen näher
ich fände es spannend ob man einfach als
dieb seine runde gewinnen kann
als die partei wirklich überhaupt keine
vorteile im pvp ist einfach ganz normal
so als hätte man gut am anfang ein
bisschen bessere sachen bekommen aber
ansonsten ist man ja eigentlich ein ganz
normaler spieler so als wenn man
holzfäller sagte der wada [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
ich hab ihn nicht gesehen hätten nur
augen gesehen all dessen co aber das ist
schlechter so schlecht dass es schlecht
auge gehabt glück gehabt leute fakt
wetten können das jetzt sterbe
oh mein gott oh mein gott jetzt schnell
dass deutschland dann rennen wir erstmal
und wir haben hier noch ein feuerzeug
das immer gute mann verfolgt wird so und
da können wir vorne also sachen
verzaubern
1 es wird es schaffen dass die wsg über
mein level 1 verzauberungen berlin auf
arte potsdam leider nur zwei
debattierten drei leveln da habe ich
wohl falsch gedacht jetzt das ist ja
auch egal
weiter gehts hier diese gegners oder im
wasser sehr gut den kübel gerne mitnimmt
sagt er ist weg alles klar
das ist natürlich schwierig man keine
gute richtung hat in einem wasser ist
dann kommt einer mit dem power 1 bogen
da hat man jetzt nicht so viele chancen
es sei denn man ist wie der vielen
kinder weg springen dann wirst du dir
viele das sind die die sozusagen im
wasser die fähigkeiten haben wie das
känguru an land hat nimmst du extrem
hohe sprünge auch ein ziemlich cooles
kit nächste geht es schon wieder relativ
nah ist ziemlich schnelle runde alles
gefühle so man mit dem apfel und die
karte auch werden ernst hat sehr gesund
rohes fleisch sehr gesund sind ja
pro sehr gute hat der der gutes sagt er
hat er nicht gut aus nein
fakt ist anderes bekommen sehe ich kaum
da hinten kommt so hinterher hinterher
ja sehr gut bis sehr gut
noch bevor er sie das ding werfen konnte
aber wenn leider nicht den dia
brustpanzer von dem anderen bekommen
das ist echt ärgerlich jetzt jemand
anders unter den nagel gerissen und wir
müssen aber noch gegen den kämpfen der
jetzt sozusagen unserem brustpanzer da
hat das ist natürlich ungünstig wir
können es aber faktisch die gäste hätten
so schön schönen gold apfel essen können
aber nein konnte ja wieder mein hunger
nicht in den griff bekommen muss jetzt
einfach diesen rp/rpo
und weiter wer mit bisher und echten
geschlagen muss ich sagen
wie gesagt die oha nur zwei leute nur
noch zwei leute dass die chance jetzt
als die diese runde first ride zu
gewinnen das er schon relativ heftig ich
würde gerne wissen was der andere punkt
hat ja da können wir observieren
wer das wasser kommt er kommt einfach
nicht der entfernt sie was sämtlichen
los was denn mit dem los
momentan ist normal muss mal schauen was
der erzähler im schilde führt vorne sich
in der den virus panzer so ärgerlich
aber er hat sonst ungefähr gar nicht so
clever snacken möchte es richtig gesehen
habe hat ist einfach richtig laut
commitment und der erste sieg als dieb
steht kurz bevor aber noch ist nichts
gewonnen deswegen ok erschreckens wasser
wenn wir zu erwischen können ja es ist
einfach ein bogen etwas ok sage ich
nicht nein aber die runde war relativ
kurz
deswegen will ich sage mach einfach
einen kurzen cut und sehen es gleich
wieder der nächsten rolle so oder so
wieder es geht weiter oder 2 mit dem die
platin jetzt die erste runde försterei
gewonnen haben mit einem kind ist
eigentlich ganz okay ich hatte eine
chance wenn ich leute dass ich gar keine
pvp die fähigkeiten mit sich bringt
haben zwei level sehr gut
davon ist eine kiste die nehme ich doch
gerne ok alles klar haben wir dabei
jetzt haben wir acht eisen zwei gold
zwei gold ist jetzt nicht die welt ich
schalte damit nachweisen kann man doch
einiges anstellen ich mal sagen die sind
ja noch kisten
nein ich sehe zwar keine doch hier ist
noch eine sehr gut das ist ein scheiß
was bist du für ein wesen das ist ein
schweizer wie du siehst aus wie die
kister du dreckige soll am 1
unverschämtheit und darum mir auch
einmal die woche die am ring ist ein
bisschen holz weil wir unbedingt eine
waffe pochen wenn die zeit vorbei ist
der neue wirt gefaltet
genial ich bin echt ein genie einfach
wie kann man so verplant seien
veränderte werten okay okay okay was
hier noch jeder schule macht man habe
jetzt schon mal eine komplette rüstung
und da vorne ist auch schon der erste
gegner
das debattenende hoffen jetzt mal der
nach uns jetzt nicht entkommen
während sich da in sicherheit sagte er
ist schon weg der den bogen mit dem
bogen vielleicht den hier ja sehr gut so
läuft das alles klar
weg damit haben jetzt mut wir haben so
wissen können dann auch direkt bisschen
brot brot greifen
was willst du denn da
kommt einer
ob ihr diese die post bei mariah okay er
brennt okay airways hat debatte die
ersten wir gerne mit fall von sich
schnell das boot dann können wir auch
etwas gebrauchen hiervon nehme ich nehme
ich nämlich zwei diaz das ist jetzt auch
nicht die welt
nächste gegner ist im naiv als jetzt
nicht die ganze zeit durchgehend japan
kann weil ich ein kleines bisschen auf
das gameplay konzentrieren damit wir da
vielleicht noch die eine oder andere
schöne szene bekommen heute läuft echt
richtig gut muss einfach sagen also mir
gefällt er hatte auch ein helm und
schuhe
die nehme ich gerne mit noch mal ein
stück bringt was ist denn los mit den
leuten den romand auch hier kaum steuern
warum sterben wie leute so schnell
gehört langsam wird dann echt lustig wie
viele leute haben jetzt schon so
ultraschnell gebildet also ohne weiteres
ab und da waren sie tot sind hier alle
lotterie
hessenwasser sagt fand den ausweg sein
findet der kann sogar am hätten
er kann sogar noch mal hinten kraft das
hätte ich nicht gedacht aha diese ändern
darf ich auf keinen fall die hauptlast
nicht nicht so nah an den kompass ich
klicke die ganze zeit auf die ender
prächtig unnötig
der volt ist es einen kleinen lied geben
aber sag ich mein
okay das ist auch weg alles klar
wir haben also noch drei verbleibenden
spieler drei verbliebenen spieler da
vorne geht weiter
70 blöcke die seite auch alle auf einem
haufen das ist echt extrem wir jetzt
gerade mal 13 minuten aufgenommen und
fast schon zwei runden gefährt
durchgespielt
alles klar dass auch weg so jetzt
hoffentlich nicht der andrea doria noch
zwei leute auf die 200 meter abstand who
ist können erstmal verschnaufen und uns
vielleicht einen brustpanzer machen was
hat man denn davon
das wäre doch mal was ja so zack da rein
noch palette holen vielleicht noch
verzaubert wiederverzauberung spenden
glück gehabt glück gehabt schon mal vor
die die es in der hand gehabt das wäre
ärgerlich gewesen
na gut so ist alles klar hierhin noch
fünf level können echt heftig verzaubern
sollten wir jetzt mal einen finden
pauschalreisen gegen gold sehr gerne
noch ein eisen bus panzer reisen lengers
machen sondern sind jetzt voller mit
ihrer mit der post panzer dass ich
ziemlich gut was soll die rüstung umgeht
haben hier noch bis zu essen
rainer mit und jetzt der feine kill der
final fight hoffentlich ein kill ist
noch nicht gesagt bisher ist es einfach
nur ein gegner der jetzt auch gern diese
runde gewinnen werden und er ist nicht
stellt gekippt
das nicht schlecht wir haben mal
getroffen mit dem bogen und er ist
scheinbar jetzt besonders beeindruckt
mit dem online portal das war richtig
dumm frontal und er dafür die bessere
rüstung gehabt schade mal es ärgert ihn
einfach zwei runden in folge gewinnen
können schade bitte immer ein bisschen
besser aufpassen können aber okay leute
wenn es euch gefallen hat und dass die
pid euch zugesagt hat oder auch nicht
dann könnt ihr einfach ein leichter
lassen
in die kommentare schreiben was ihr als
nächstes sehen wollt welche skate oder
will ich sagen sie selbst bei der
nächsten folge wieder oldtimer schau